hier ist die
Feuerwehr so und jetzt vorne rein
feuerfrei rein re wir gehen rechts wir
gehen rechts wir fahren immer dahin wo
die Leute nicht weiter wissen so ganz
doof gesagt wir rennen da rein wo die
anderen
rausrennen erstm bisschen zurück wir
trennen gleich und verschieben dann
liegt
da ich glaube dass der Job ein
tatsächlich verändert also ich muss für
mich selber feststellen dass ich gelernt
habe das Leben viel mehr zu
[Musik]
genießen sch
anrufeohnung vier
obergeschossach als Kind hatte ich
tatschlich trauri Geschichte
dramatisches Erlebnis es war ein
verkehrsumfall wo viele Leute drum
rumgestanden haben und nicht helfen
konnten und das hat mir als Kind damals
schon eingebleut dass ich nicht
dieserjenige sein möchte der guckt
sondern der
hilft guck gleich schon raucholeshen oh
ja ja wenn man auf anfah schon
Rauchsäule sieht dann steigt das andin
auf jeden Fall an man weiß es ist keine
Fehlermeldung oder kein Fehlalarm man
weiß das es wirklich was größer
chollen men komplett durchrollen hier
rückwärts ja ich bin Feuermann geworden
weil ich das aus Überzeugung mache es
macht mir super viel Spaß habe das schon
in meiner Kindheit mitbekommen durch
mein Pa mein Opa mein Cousinen die alle
be der Feuerwehr waren und das war immer
mein größter
Traum darum okay da sind keine
Aufstellflächen wir müssen noch mehr was
hier Leitung legen Leute das Problem war
halt dass wir dort keine Drehleiter
aufstellen konnten wir haben tragbare
Leitern die allerdings nur bis zum
dritten Stockwerk reichen das heißt
Wohnung über den dritten Stockwerk
hätten wir leider nicht erreichen können
ja mal die Länge einmal Kuppel die mal
an Vorsicht
[Musik]
Vorsicht meine Aufgabe war es dann in
den Innenangriff zu gehen ausgerüstet
mit
schnellangriffschlauch
schlauchtragekörben
Brechwerkzeug Wärmebildkamera und unser
Atemschutz sind wir dann bis ins vierte
og
hochmarschiert
[Musik]
ja seid ihr
bereit
[Musik]
so wie es immer ist man fängt gerade an
dann darf man
los ja wir sind ja quasi hier immer auf
Abhub ich finde das zurzeit ist noch so
ein aufregendes Gefühl man kann
jederzeit rausfahren man kann man weiß
ja nie was zuuk kommt ich glaube
langzeitig gesehen ist es vielleicht
doch etwas was dann noch gesundheitlich
belasten kann also wenn man halt immer
irgendwie unter Stress
ist ich das jetzt Notfall BW heißt es
ein Notfall auf einer
[Musik]
Autobahn bitte nicht in die Kolonne
einfahren hallo können Sie mal zur Seite
fahren so nicht normal oder
ich weiß nicht also teilweise sind die
Autos ja mittlerweile so gut isoliert
dass die das gar nicht wahrnehmen die
das Martin
Horn aber ja me sind auch nicht gewillt
Platz zu machen ist schon kurios bleib
mal hier hinter stehen den einmal mit
rettungsdienstkponente nach vorne
[Musik]
kommen
könnt i mal gerne gucken einm gucken
genau mehr oder weniger unverletzte Frau
vorne ja es ging darum dass ein
Lastwagen ein PKW touchiert hatte dieser
PKW sich dann gedreht hat und mehrere
Meter von dem Lastwagen vorwegeschoben
worden ist moin hallo sie saßen in dem
in dem roten in dem roten er hat mich
halt mitgenommen ist ein zweimal gegen
und dann hat sich das Auto gedreht wie
geht's ihn jetzt mir ist schlecht
schlecht okay aber die Aufregung ja sie
sind nicht verletzt i tut nichts weh
Kopfschmerzen ein bisschen aber ja sie
ist rechts gefahren warim toten Winkel
und er wollte die Spur wechseln hat die
gar nicht gesehen und dann ist sie
schräg vorm Auto gekommen und er hat sie
weggeschoben das ist natürlich da hast
du drinne Todesangst ne weil wenn der
weiter über sie rüber fährt dann
aber zum Glück nicht verletzt nur Schock
wir müssen hier weg weil das ist hier
sehr enge blöde Stelle deshalb hat die
Bock
gut
wenn wir Einsätze auf anstraßen haben
auf Autobahn muss man wirklich enorm
aufpassen die die Autofahrer die passen
nicht unbedingt auf sie sehen es
vielleicht auch gar nicht direkt was da
los ist andererseits gibt's die die
natürlich gaffen die gucken wollen
dadurch könen natürlich auch Unfälle
entstehen klar es ist alles
gefährlich die Einsatzstellen das ist
nicht das sicherste was wir da machen
aber ich ich ma mir persönlich über mich
selber gar keine
Gedanken aber ich weiß z.B dass meine
Mutter sich sehr große Gedanken immer
macht die sagt ich möch gar nicht wissen
was du da alles macht sie ist heilfoh
wenn ich morgens wieder heil nach Hause
komme und ja mich dann mal irgendwann
bei ihr melde sag ist alles gut und mir
geht
super ja wir fahren jetzt das Auto in
Kolonne mit der Polizei also es
verunfallte Auto runter von der Autobahn
das macht gerade ein Kollege von mir der
fährt das Auto jetzt runter und da wird
sich dann WE
[Musik]
gekummert ich werde immer wieder gefragt
weil ich ein so ein unfassbar schüchter
Mensch gerade früher war und jetzt
teilweise immer noch bin wie ich das in
meinem Job vereinen
kann vielleicht s zu wissen ich war
früher zwar an der Wache unglaublich
schüchtern also nie mit Menschen
großartig geredet eher zurückgezogen
gelernt aber im Einsatz habe ich gar
nicht auchgörz Bren das heiß mein
gesamtes wortkontingent Habe ich einach
in diesem einen Einsatz paar Einsätze an
dem Tag rausspruddeln lassen vielleicht
ist es tatsächlich die Uniform die mich
dazu bringt immer mit Leuten in Kontakt
zu treten und ich würde eher andersum
denken gerade weil ich bei der Arbeit
viel mit Menschen reden muss hat mich
das eher in privaten viel viel weiter
gebracht weil ich im Privaten jetzt sehr
gut auch mit Menschen kommunizieren kann
wo ich vorher gedachteber nicht
nachfragen geh
los geh rein rein
re unten bleiben schön unten bleiben ja
der Moment ist ziemlich aufregend weil
man nicht weiß was einem erwartet man
hat erstmal eigentlich nichts gesehen
mach mal deine Lampe
an wir gehen rechts wir gehen
rechts was sieht aus wie ein lagergang
Lager ja nee sieht gut aus beim
Durchsuchen der Wohnung muss man sich
halt entscheiden wo lang geht man
dadurch dass man halt überhaupt nicht
sehen konnte vielleicht eine Sichtweite
von 20 cm hatte haben uns rechts lang
gehangelt mit der Hilfe der
Wärmebildkamera
warte wir warm ja ja war das muss von
oben kommen Tür oder nee hier rechts ist
ein
Schrank wir sind im Schlafzimmer wir
hatten vorher schon die Information
gekriegt dass wir alle Anwohner aus
dieser Wohnung raus sein sollten und
sich nur noch eine Katze da drin
befinden kann eine
katzeck hier ist nich hier ist n
gefunden ja geh mal ja hier ist doch
alles lass mal
ab wir haben die komplette Wohnung
durchsucht kein Feuer ist alles am
abklimmen und löschen die
glutnäer ich habe die Katze gefunden
die
Katze er Katze Brandrauch ist echt eine
gefährliche Sache je nachdem also wie
schnell man raust kann man es vielleicht
noch retten aber da war der Rauch zu
dick und die Katze zu lange drin dass da
sliche Hilfe zu spät kam für
[Musik]
sie Kollegen kon dort nicht mehr viel
leider retten die ist unbewohnbar alles
an Hab und Gut ist einfach nicht mehr
nutzbar alles was dort ist alle
Klamotten muss leider
entsorgt werden der Brandrauch ist halt
so stark der ist überall drin alle
Sachen die alles was man hat in so einer
Wohnung das kann weg das was am
körpertruck ist das einzige was er jetzt
noch hat und der Rest ist wohl den
Brandrauch zu Opfer gekommen no mal
genauieren obank Feuer war oder nur eine
starke naladung
hat hier drin gebrannt in der Wohnung
wir haben kein Feuer
gesehen und
B kann von her das muss von außen
irgendwie ja doch das kann sein das kann
sogar sehr gut
sein man freut sich wenn Feuer hatlich
ist es zum Leid eines anderen immer
unsere Freude aber man freut sich
natürlich dann auch auf die geleistete
Arbeit und sieht wenn alles super hat
und man ja auch größeres verhindert
dadurch aber letztes Jahr im Dezember
hatten wir ein großes Feuer in der
Flüchtlingsunterkunft ist leider auch
einer
verstorben natürlich hat man auch
bilderereignisse die man sieht die
einprägend sind die man verarbeiten muss
ich habe das ganz gut mit meiner Frau
kann ich über alles reden und verarbeite
das so neh ich es einfach wieder
erzähl ich denke schon dass mein Beruf
mich schon wirklich sehr prägt man ist
einfach zufriedener weil man einfach
wirklich das schätzt was man hat hat und
dass es einem gut geht dass man gesund
ist und natürlich hat man immer viele
Träume aber man ist auch einfach
schneller mal mit dem zufrieden was man
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hatsere Arbeit
die Meldung war
Anaphylaxie also allergische Reaktion
sozusagen übersetzt mal in in mein
Deutsch weil so medizinerisch spreche
ich noch gar nicht so moin hallo schönen
guten Abend und habe ich auch gedagt
okay hatte ich noch nicht spannt was uns
da erwartet ich habe es scampies
gegessen und
Trüffel
okay und jetzt juckt das alles und es
wird dick wird dick okay gut ich bekomme
immer schlechter Luft okay mhm dann hat
man auch gesehen die Frau die braucht
wirklich Hilfe ne also man hat das
gesehen dass sie
schlecht Luft bekommt dass die Zunge
angeschwollen war und da haben wir
gesagt okay wir sind richtig hier einmal
Sauerstoff 9 l machen wir immer über die
Maske mm danach bereitest Du mal Zugang
vor und ziehst vor noch mal Adrenalin
auf 0,5 mg wir geben ihn gleich mal
Medikament und dann wird das mit der
Schwellung bisschen besser ne so sie
kriegen von mir hier einmal über die
Maske ein bisschen Sauerstoff ne wenn
das mit der Brille stört sagen sie auch
Bescheid ne genau ich lupfe hier
vorsichtig einmal an da ich ja
Rettungssanitäter bin und und Win
Notfallsanitäter und dem dementsprechend
no Einsatzleiter das er mich da wie
gesagt an die Hand genommen gesagt hier
Lukas das brauchen wir das brauchen wir
und ich habe ihm so gut es geht
zugearbeitet Blutdruck hattest du schon
gestartet Blutdruck hat ich noch nicht
gestartet okay genau dann wird's jetzt
noch mal eng am linken Arm genau vor
noch einmal Adrenalin aufziehen bitte
0,5 mg halber
Ampulle juckt das hier auch alles
fängt an fängt an zu jucken das jetzt
hier 0,9 bisschen rausgegang Adrenalin
die Menge die ich dort anmtig also für
mich die Menge die ich dort an
Medikation aufziehen durfte war
natürlich auch relativ neu habe ich die
aufgezogen falsche Spritze ne da habe
ich z. auch gelernt dass ich die falsche
spritzgröße verwendet habe ich habe
nicht genau gesehen wie win das gemacht
aber ich glaube er hat sich das
dahinchinscht das ist Paste versuchen
sie schön tief ein und auszuatmen die
Sauerstoffs wird auch schon besser das
heißt zeigt Wirkung wir nehmen Sie auf
jeden Fall mal mit ins Krankenhaus fährt
leider führt leider keinen Weg dran
vorbei von wo kommen Sie denn
äh von denburg wo Hessen okay und jetzt
hier steht der Trip in Hamburg dann
kannst du schon mal ein Transport
vorbereiten ja einmal mit dem ebug chair
ja es hat geschüttet also typisches
Hamburger
schiedwetter und dann so okay wie finde
ich den Weg wieder zurück welches Zimmer
habt ihr es mit Zimmernummer oh shit
Vincent kleiner irgarten
[Musik]
hier wir gehen einmal geradeaus rein oh
wir machen bisschen Kuschelparty ja oh
das war eng das war kuschig uns kurz nah
gekommen
ne ja sind wir ich
drück ist
drin so nicht erschrecken geht jetzt
einmal rückwärts in
Rettungswagen
wir können los wenn i irgendwie trotzdem
schlecht werden sollte oder sowas dann
sagen sie Bescheid aber lassen sich
nicht durch den Wind bringen das
schaukelt immer so W wir sind
da perfekt hast du das Tablet oder ja
ich habe alle C3 und Tablet sehr schön
geht einmal ins Krankenhaus einige
Handgriffe weil relativ frisch bin sind
no ganz neu für mich gerade die
Medikamente aufziehen und so das haben
wir natürlich alles in der in der
Theorie auch in der Praxis gelernt aber
das war für mich so das erste Mal dass
ich so viel an Medikamenten aufgezogen
habe da habe ich dir eine zu große
Spritze gegeben ja s kein Problem haben
wir trotzdem hinbekommen weiß ich fürs
nächste Mal also du willst eine kleinere
haben D genau n mal eine kleinere damit
wir das einfach besser dosieren kann ich
habe vorher die Hälfte rausgelassen aus
der Spritze das war alles in Ordnung
also konntest du damit arbeiten ich
konnte damit arbeiten genau okay das war
für mich war das ein spannender Einsatz
auch wenn wiincent sagt das ist
alltägliches Geschäft
für mich ja noch gar nicht so ne also
für mich war das der erste Einsatz was
das anging und total
[Musik]
aufregend mein Papa ist auch bei der
Berufsfeuerwehr mein Papa hat immer
gesagt mach alles geht nur nicht zur
Feuerwehr so nach dem Motto also es er
war nicht dieser typische Papa der
gesagt hat du musst jetzt nur noch mit
Feuerwehr Spielzeug spielen hat mich in
diese Richtung gedrückt und hat gesagt
mach einfach das wozu du Bock hast und
wenn es Feuerwehr ist ist natürlich toll
und ich habe ihn glaube ich auch stolz
gemacht gesagt Papa ich habe es denn
doch doch noch mal überlegt ich möchte
doch zur
Feuerwehr ja bald steht meine
Vereidigung an und ich bin total
aufgeregt und freue mich auf den
Tag moin moin also ich bin jetzt noch zu
Hause wir haben jetzt VI 58 das mein
normaler dienstrhythmus ich ma mich
gleich auf dem Weg 2055 uh fahre ich
hier los ca fahre auf dem Weg bei
matthiasbei Matthias auch mit zum Dienst
wir fahren meistens zusammen wenn wir
gleichen Dienstschicht
haben und ich bin gespannt was der Tag
uns so
bringt abgesehen vom frühen Aufstehen
fah ichich gerne
dorthin sind wir heute
ersten ungtafel und wir dürfen heute den
angriffstr Spielen sieht das an unseren
[Gelächter]
wildernen oder was mal
rein und dann sind wir gespannt was
[Musik]
passiert wir wden recht schnell aus
unserer Entspannungsphase am Morgen der
übergabezeit mit dem Kaffee den wir zu
dem Zeitpunkt noch gar nicht
hatten
alarmiert eine
Person auf dem Weg dahin macht man sich
eigentlich die meisten Gedanken und wenn
man dann da ist funktioniert
man ich bin dann hochgegangen und da kam
uns schon die lockführerin
entgegen
die den die Person dann überrollt hatte
und die war natürlich fix und fertig
Käse weiß hat geweint und gezittert und
so für die ist es eigentlich mit am
Schlimmsten was da passiert weil die das
natürlich unmittelbar auch mitkriegen
und sehen was da passiert ein Messgerät
h mal ein messgät
raus gut wir gehen nach vorne wir haben
uns die
u-bahnerdung dazu geholt das heißt also
bevor wir ins Gleisbett steigen müssen
wir vor und hinter dem Fahrzeug die
Gleise Erden damit wir keinen
Stromschlag bekommen willst du messen
oder soll ich
messen okay okay
spannungsfrei
gut Fahrzeugführer für 231 Angriffsdruck
kommen in Fahrtrichtung Spannung ist
freier
jetzt
Erdung in Fahrtrichtung gesetzt wir
haben jetzt geerdet wir trennen gleich
und müssen verschieden
personenin Erdung haben
wir